un ataque de 20 personas fuertemente
armadas al estilo sicariato se produjo
en el puerto pesquero artesanal de la
provincia costera de esmeraldas según el
informe policial la lucha de territorio
y enfrentamientos entre grupos
delincuencia organizada son los motivos
de los ataques producidos en Ecuador
recientemente en medio de una gran
crisis de inseguridad que vive el país
el ataque se produjo con armas cortas y
armas largas según informó el titular y
Justicia ecuatoriano Juan Zapata quien
confirmó que en el lugar existe más de
200 indicios balísticos registrados en
el lugar del suceso la Policía Nacional
y las fuerzas armadas desarrollan
operativo y se han confirmado 60
allanamientos hasta el momento para
capturar hacia los responsables sucedió
cuando los atacantes llegaron por mar y
por tierra y dispararon
indiscriminadamente cuando se
encontraban dos mil personas en el
sector entre pesqueros y comerciantes
según informaron las autoridades el
ministro de interior y Justicia confirmó
que los ataques son consecuencias de
operativos en contra el narcotráfico y
el crimen organizado que intenta cambiar
a la modalidad de las vacunas a
comerciantes la provincia de Esmeralda
se mantuvo en un estado de sección desde
el 3 de marzo hasta el 10 de Abril donde
se decomisaron solo en esta provincia
1403 kilogramos de droga y se
desarticularon a cinco grupos
organizados los trabajadores que se
encontraban en el lugar se lanzaron al
mar para intentar sobrevivir al ataque
armado la provincia de esmeraldas maneja
la tasa de muertes más violentas del
país con un promedio de 16 asesinatos
por